i'm gonna go with steve weintraub
collider how are you doing today sir
steven i'm uh very very well and i'm
curious to know what that is over your
left shoulder
uh this could be a iron man uh bust
um you might i was gonna make a joke you
might be familiar from this thing uh
with this thing due to your involvement
in current marvel projects but anyway
sure hi
well let's hope you're right
i'm i'm very confident about your uh i'm
very confident i will leave it there um
and just say i i am a huge fan of your
work and i really want to thank you for
everything from star trek to professor x
just i i just want to thank you for your
work
thank you
um i i definitely want to know when you
were making next generation you were
doing sometimes 26 episodes a season and
now you're filming picard season two and
then you know and you're wrapping up
with season three and i know it was back
to back has it sort of felt a little bit
like old times in terms of playing
picard you know like filming 20 episodes
it has been quite different
because
i was 46
the first time i put on john luke's
uniform
and i'm putting on something now star
trek something
and i'm 81
so that has
my perception of what is happening has
changed and a ten and a half hour day
which i worked yesterday
um
is no longer
easily absorbed and
put to sleep
and put into the the uh
the past
bracket
not at all i i am um
actually i was very generously by our
line producer released from the last
hour or so of um
of work yesterday because i was just
getting too tired to do the job
and um so
uh stamina and health
um and i'm not happy to say i have
well i had
we shut down for two weeks but that was
not really my responsibility
i'm doing fine
and
i
seriously wanted to continue as long as
possible
i know that you're currently filming the
series finale of uh picard season three
um and uh i'm just curious uh what does
it mean to you
to
have gotten to play the character again
you know um and also obviously what can
you tease fans
about this ultimate journey that he's on
between season two and three
you they will find uh watchers followers
of picard will find
that
we get to the very end of season three
and
the resolution
is unexpected
and questionable
and um i'm thrilled about that because
it leaves a question mark hanging over
his head now i'm not saying
in three years time or ten years time
there will be another series and i'll be
back again
tending in my grapes in the vineyard but
um
[Music]
i i've had some fallings out with some
of our people because
they look on this as a closure that is
coming up
and i don't i'm very now i'm so curious
about this um i already got a rap i'm
just gonna say i am so also so happy
that you will be in doctor strange too
perhaps and um you know i'll say it like
that
the world seems to know much more about
that than i do
right i cannot wait on that note you
know have a fantastic day and thank you
so much for everything well stephen uh
it's been a pleasure to talk to you
thank you